Matthew when did you decide you wanted
to be a writer I decided to write at
school I think when I wrote my essays at
school you know when you had to write
something for school like a kind of a I
don't know what you would call it
descriptive essay or something like that
and I remember writing essays at school
and really enjoying the process and
being quite experimental with what I
wrote and the teachers didn't really
like that so I remember once writing a
very descriptive story about it the deck
it was a photograph of a deck chair and
a beach and they said writer
I think they said write a descriptive
essay so they wanted me to describe the
scene but I got all metaphorical and I
was I said the deck chair wants to get
through the barrier run across the beach
into eternity like symbolism the whole
thing became symbolic for me so I wrote
this like a non simplest thing and I
loved it I kind of escaped into the
writing and then I remember a teacher
was like oh no that's that's not what we
met and gave me like this really low
mark and then so I didn't actually write
for a very long time after that but I
enjoyed escaping into writing and I've
always read a lot from a very young age
I've escaped into books and I think I
think if you read a lot you kind of want
to write in some way maybe or it's an
easy kind of jump and then when I was at
university no I was when I left school I
didn't go to university straight away I
worked for a photographic company
delivering photographic accessories and
I remember writing a poem I was inspired
by this tree that's really not a tree
and I wrote a poem in the diary that I
kept for like my work diary on the page
and at that moment I was like oh I might
be creative this is interesting and I
remember telling some of my friends like
almost like a secret like I think I
might be creative and they were like of
course you are and I was like and then
from then on I think rioting has just
been something that's sort of gnawed at
me too you know stories come to be told
and and that's I think that's where it
came from so yeah I mean it's a it's
been an interesting journey and I think
that's where I first wanted to write and
then I just started yeah and you also
have a meditation practice I do yeah I
do
thank goodness and I did a 10-day silent
meditation retreat sort of much later in
life I mean the poetry writing was early
and then I went to study screenwriting
in the UK and came back and started
writing scripts for television in South
Africa and then many many years later I
started meditating and that's where I
think I found the sense of calm and a
sense of peace in the creative process
being less reactive and more sort of
active in the way I wrote so yeah that's
been an interesting journey so once you
got past the sort of hiding that you
were creative stage how often did you
begin writing mmm again you're asking me
these great questions North Austin
I wouldn't say I was a prolific writer
I'm not someone who finds writing the
writing process easy and I don't write
everyday I find that there's the saying
that I once heard that something like
you know sort of real writers find it
hard to write it's like it difficult you
know it's like a struggle I think if
we're not real writers but I think to
get stuff out there that matters to me
it's can be a bit of a struggle even
just sitting down on the chair I mean
there's other great quote of writing as
the fine art of applying the seat of
your pants to the seat of a chair yeah
what I like about that is for me writing
is like I have to arrange my life to
find the time to write so when I wrote
my book I had to literally put in my
diary 9 to 12 I'm writing every day and
that's it no matter what happens people
found me and they'd say you know can you
teach this course of that he's if it's 9
to 12 I can't do it so blocking out the
time in my life to write is is an art
form so that's why I think it's writing
is the fine art of applying to see if
your pens to your chair see if it shows
like how do you find how do you kind of
manage your life in that way I know a
lot of writers that I know have found
ways to chose a lot of time so I guess
my writing my sort of I suppose my
writing for myself as in writing on spec
forgot a deadline that's great
so I think my and the University when I
studied it in the UK the writing I did
there was all sort of deadlines based
you know sorrow hollers short scripts
and then longer scripts and then feature
films were a feature film while I was
there and that was deadline based
writing so that was quite easy for me to
do and then when I was doing that I read
a children's book and these ideas come
to me and like I said they like these
little chicks that I can't ignore and
you know they come nibbling at my feet
and I'm like write me you write me and
then eventually if I give them enough
time and and focus then our I will I
will write them but it's been a it's
been a long difficult process in terms
of writing what I want to write and I'm
still learning actually to write you
know the stuff that's inside me that
wants to come out because for example
the sitcoms that I wrote I mean those
were deadlines based as well and that
was just like I mean I think I wrote 25
sitcoms or something in South Africa
sitcom episodes and they were just like
that was
that was in television you know it was
like fast turnaround time and I was
writing with a writing partner I really
like doing running with partners I like
sort of collaborating a lot and that was
good cuz that had deadlines so I think
writing then was just it just kind of
because it was deadline writing I kind
of had to do it and then I did it but
yeah if that answers your question but
yeah and then occasionally other stories
come to me like I wrote a feature film
about growing up in suburbia which was
an about escaping suburbia with a very
loosely veiled character called Michael
not Matthew who's not me at all and it's
basically about how he tries to escape
out of suburbia and the more he tries
them where he gets sucked into this sort
of dark underbelly of suburbia
but it's suburbia on the tip of Africa
in Cape Town so it's but it's just like
suburbia anyway really so that story
came to me and then I just I kind of
have to ride it and then I have to go on
like some sort of a retreat and I went
away and found a quiet place and then
just wrote that I found getting the
first draft out is there that's what
takes the time yeah well excuse me what
is the underbelly of suburbia I'd love
to hear about it
oh okay so in this story that under boat
the underbelly of suburbia is based on
on kind of my my life in in tableview
where I grew up which is small suburban
town area in Cape Town
it's a biker gang so a sort of like a
biker gang with deals with drugs and
organizes swingers parties and look all
very but it's all very kind of lower
Brad's funny really you know the guy
who's the biker gang leader is you know
he's just a kind of a big cuddly bear of
a man he he doesn't want anyone to get
out of his grasp you know and he has a
bit of a history with this guy's father
and so yeah and so he gets he he owes
the guy money event sheep sort of
gambling debt I guess and then he just
gets more and more sucked in he just
can't get away and he's dead is an ATM
repairman which existed in those days
and he has access to all the ATMs and
this guy wants access and so the more
Michael tries to get away the more this
guy tries to manipulate into the you but
he tries to get him to betray his dad
and give him access to away so it's kind
of like money and you know dodgy
dealings in the underbelly of suburbia
including swingers parties and
strange stuff that Michael gets
distracted them yeah do you think one of
the things with suburbia is the need to
conform and anybody who violates that
like norm is then suspect even though
everybody kind of wants to already
violate that but they too afraid
absolutely I think so so my experience
of suburbia was when when I was really
young we moved to an area that was quite
pristine almost like a wilderness area
hmm and it was beautiful and we didn't
even have taught roads they were very
few houses around so there was lots of
empty lots with you know just shrubs and
bushes growing in it but then the
tableview which is the small area became
the fastest-growing suburb in the
southern hemisphere and just expanded so
things really happened really quickly
around me Todd roads pavements malls
which were never there before and so
literally I felt suburbia grow up around
me when I was younger and it was really
like I I definitely have an aversion to
suburbia because I was in this pristine
beautiful wilderness the next thing I
know I'm in a concrete jungle and
exactly there was a sort of formal
formative time of my life and so I think
suburbia does try and fit you into a
certain thing this suburb is still
growing and what they do is they they
just kind of care out some land they
build roads and then they put up a mall
before the houses come it's bizarre they
put up like a mall and they put up like
a gas station and then the houses come
and it's like they're really trying to
get you to fit in a certain way you know
it's just the way I think it's just it's
easier to manage as a space and I guess
if you don't fit in there yeah I
certainly riled against suburbia
I am in a big way suburbia does try and
make you conform I think it does it does
and I think if you that what is there's
a quote from a song conformed or be cast
out and so it's sometimes fun to be the
outcast yeah we have something in common
yeah do you think with meditation
because you you meant
and earlier that you'd like to have a
certain you know your life organized
around you and you have these very
organized times that meditation also
helps organize the thoughts definitely
okay yeah I think yeah it does I'm
actually it doesn't yeah it definitely
does organize the thoughts I think in it
yeah I don't know it way to take that
yeah that's fine no we could just leave
it at that would yeah I just I just
thought that was interesting cuz you
mentioned how you like this organization
and and I and if there's maybe too much
chaos then it's not I think a lot of the
chaos is in my own mind if you know what
I mean so it's interesting there can be
a lot of demands of our time in terms of
work are the people but also of my mind
you know I could wake up in the morning
and have an open day where I could write
but my mind is just I'm having the
internal battle you know with myself and
my thoughts and my you know questions
are you worthy enough are you good
enough you know is this is the story
good enough all these kind of things of
are you enough you know in meditation
for me helps me to just calm the moment
down slow the mind on and just be and
then creating from that space is a very
interesting and liberating space because
I'm not feeling judged by myself or by
anyone right and sometimes there's just
like these little things that I remember
one time someone said to me why are you
giving that free rent in your head I was
like oh wow she's nuts
yeah I am okay we'll stop that's a
really nice way of putting it what type
of writer did you want to be I know you
said you attended screenwriting business
in the UK our goals you've got such
great questions I actually wanted to be
a film director and not a writer so when
I was in grade seven the the headmaster
of my school said was that career day
and they were like what do you want to
be and I said I want to be a film
director like I knew from that age I
wanted to be a film director I love them
so much I used to escape in it all the
time and his response was not ideal it
was like no you can't do that in this
country
South Africa you can't be that tell me
what else you want to be so I'd like
lefties office devastated I was I know
already and I looked around I saw a lot
of black nature spaces wilderness spaces
and I loved escaping into nature so I
went back and I said okay I'll be a game
Ranger and he said much better do
geography and then take me off the list
and that was it
I think he just wanted me to put me in a
stream and there was no scream for film
director so they were like okay game
Ranger that's a good good choice so I so
I knew from a very young age that I
wanna be a film director and I used to
always play with video cameras and VHS
tapes recording from one to another and
doing editing and souse always in that
space of yeah I guess of being a film
director and I had stories come to me
even at that age but I was always
thinking of them in terms of foam I
never really realized that screenwriting
was something that happened and then
when I went to university I I studied
English because I was kind of close to
to writing or or film they would they
did a film stuff in English and
environmental in geographical science
which was the gameranger thing so even
young even at that age I was school like
hedging my bets you know gameranger
or filmmaker and so I've yeah from a
very very young age I've always wanted
to make films of some kind and I think
it depended on what phones I was
watching as to what kind of films I
would want to make so when I was younger
I want to make like you know action and
adventure stories and then as I got
older I was more interested in the
experimental film so then I wanted to
make experimental platforms and now I'm
just interested in I suppose
life and drama and they're the real
stuff you know with subtleties of
emotion and complexities of life and
those are the stories that aren't there
and I just I'm now interested in so I
never really had an aim to be a
particular kind of writer but I guess a
serious writer is whatever kind of
always wanted to be yeah I Nev that
answers your question but yeah it does
how did you feel Americans showed cinema
versus maybe the South African mindset I
know that different yeah places have
different mindsets different things
happen historically yeah it's ironic
that my head most amazing right in some
ways principal and equals you my
principal yeah headmaster
oh right right yeah they might he may
have
right in some ways because the south
african film industry even though it's
growing and there's been some really
good films coming out of south africa
and there's been you know we did taht
see which one best foreign film a couple
of years ago gavin who'd moved out here
and there's a lot of south african
directors who when they sort of make it
they move to LA our film industry is
definitely growing but we have a problem
with distribution so the majority of our
population this is the historical
factors of filmmaking in south africa
the majority of our population live in
very very poor surroundings so so every
is one of the most unequal societies in
the world and so people who live in i
guess you could call them we call them
townships like squatter camps i guess
haven't got money to spend on
entertainment in the way that going to a
cinema would be or even buying a netflix
account or anything like that
you'll find your movies other ways
they'll be pirated deviant things you'll
find other ways of getting your
entertainment and there is also good
television entertainment so in south
africa
the problem is distribution so we don't
have the the finances really available
to make the kind of movies and as many
movies as we'd like to make so there is
there are some movies that get made and
as I say it's growing every year which
is great when technology becomes easier
to afford we're making more more movies
but we just don't have that like when
I'm here in America I just see the AMC
cinemas I'm like wow these what you go
AMC diner and you sing and your foods
coming to you gotta see the decline I'm
like we have that in South Africa they
call prestige cinemas only really rich
people can afford them whereas here it
seems like a lot of people well not
everyone but a lot of people can afford
to go to the cinema and so you can
afford to have a very healthy industry
whereas in South Africa it's tiny and so
we you know and it's expensive making a
movie so yeah this is what this is what
happens is the film industry culture in
South Africa although I like about it is
it's very gung-ho anyone with the camera
can make a film you know you just go off
then you make them there's a huge
independent spirit to making films in
Safra which I like but we just don't
have the studio Peter next few years
there's the studio tiny existence of
Africa we have production companies that
make movies that then get distribution
deals but there's no studio system so
even if you have a script doing the
rounds we'll do round 2 like three or
four people and then it's time
yeah that's it there's just those three
new people you know them and they come
around to your house and you you know
you don't want to mention them I've got
a great script because they're just your
friends so yeah it's kind of a smallish
cottage industry yeah
what's the fastest way to learn
screenwriting the fastest way of
learning screenwriting is very easy read
scripts that's simple so people who
write novels very often just sit down in
the computer and they start writing but
chances are they've read lots of novels
in their lives
almost certainly so there's this famous
saying you know if you want to learn how
to write you just read read read and
write write write
so script writing is exactly the same
read lots of scripts what I find really
strange is participants of my workshops
and people who come to my talks and
stuff I'm like how many of you have read
a feature film script and like out of
the 40 people maybe it's a South African
thing but not many people have read of
features on script but they want to
write movies because they've watched
lots of movies so they think because
they're a movie fan and they like to
watch movies that they can write scripts
and I'm like but you've never seen this
document of a script properly you may
have read you know transcriptions of
scripts but you never looked at the
formatting and the layout and the style
and the structure and all this kind of
thing so I would say just read as many
scripts as you can and they're all
available online you know they are
websites where you can get them and just
because I mean I think that's how we
learn it's just from reading and I mean
if you read many many feature film
scripts then you're not practically -
that's tough for me that's the fast
track to writing good scripts is reading
lots of scripts and they're there it's
available you can read the screen
writing books on how to write scripts
but really if you just read the scripts
lots of them and keep up to date with
what's happening in the trends of the
writing styles and how things are
changing through the years so you know
don't just read Casablanca and Chinatown
because there are certain formatting at
a certain time read current scripts as
well interested in TV series we TV
series scripts because they're also
written in a different style and then
you start to see the writers voice and
then perhaps from that you can start
writing your own voice so I would say
the fast track is just read loads of
scripts then of course write the scripts
so my first trip that I ever wrote does
not exist anymore anyway in this world I
hope there's no digital copy of it it
was terrible
it probably had a lot of formatting
errors it was it was just you know
wasn't terrible it was just misguided
youth enthusiasm of youth so you've got
to write quite a lot to get that stuff
audio system I think
you know you get the genius writer you
may write a further script and it's like
fantastic but I'd say write a few times
and see how it works get feedback as
well from people who are not your mother
or your best friend and and then
rewrites that script and then you'll
start to get somewhere yeah that's I
suppose that's the fast-track to you to
writing it goes without saying that one
needs to watch lots of movies or
television and BC you know steeped in
that world yeah and then to make it
really good I was gonna say read the
book three walls of screenwriting but
well that's your book yeah yeah okay but
what I want to say is tap into what only
you can bring into the script so it's
all very well reading loads of scripts
and writing those the scripts if you're
gonna write another crime thriller or
you know something that someone else can
do better
what can you write what's the only in
the story that only you can roll the
stories and you can write all the themes
of any you can write if you can tap into
that then you are really putting
something in there that is authentic and
it'll read people will recognize it when
they read it immediately so I added a
lot of script reading in the past and
for competitions and I've read too many
scripts I yeah for my own sanity but
when you're reading them you you
suddenly something just leaps off the
page and that's an authenticity it's a
moment of realness a real character
moment a real moment of subtlety a real
location a real something that just
leaps off the page if you can put that
in your scripts and I really believe
that you'll have an advantage over of at
the script so yeah read lots of scripts
and write the kinda scripts and you can
write and what was the first script that
you read oh that's another great
question hmm
do you remember the year it was probably
quite late I was a while of replace are
you the first things I read would play
as stage plays before I read scripts
things like waiting for God and these
like plays that are you know the
standard plays you read if you're doing
an English degree or something it in
South Africa we've read some plays and
the first script I read was probably
Cinema Paradiso and if you know that
it's a it's a movie but an Italian
filmmaker Giuseppe Tornatore
anyone needed one the many many years
ago it was beautiful movie Cinema
Paradiso and shot it and it's great and
I love that movie and I think that was
the first script I ever bought and the
first script I had reread but just the
KVA goes it was one of those
transcripted scripts that you can buy so
it's like a book version of a script and
it's you know it's got all the dialogue
and settlement and some of the action
but it wasn't formatted in a correct
script format I think the first one I
probably read was Chinatown in proper
script formatting but I remember buying
the book of cinema paradiso and reading
it and being able to picture all the
scenes in my head and that's a that's a
real skill that people kind of have to
develop you know you've got to buy the
you've got to read these scripts to
picture it in your head to feel what it
feels like so that when you write it you
can make someone picture those scenes in
their head it's a it's a different thing
I often say that for me when people
think they can write scripts without
reading scripts it's like going to a
classical concert and listening to a
piece of classical music and thinking oh
I love this music I'm gonna go home and
write some music now and just writing
music randomly with dots and squiggles
because you know there's dots and
squiggles and lines and just kind of
writing some sort of a document that's
you think looks like sheet music and
then handing it over to someone and
expecting them to play they're not gonna
understand and it's like a architect
going and if you see a beautiful
building and you think oh this
building's really beautiful I love this
building and I like buildings and I
understand buildings and I like Art Deco
style I'm gonna go home and design a
building and you just kind of design the
building without having looked at
blueprints or read sheet music that's
why you got to read scripts and movie is
not a script it's a it's a different
thing they serve different kind of
functions almost so yeah
so so you can't be Frank Gehry unless
you yeah exactly you right yeah right
right and the same thing you can't be
William Goldman yeah we just did
whatever you wanted Radian although I do
think that yeah it's all about being
able to evoke an emotion in the reader
so maybe they could they can do that
they really had a way of doing it
somehow in their writing you know so
that's yeah I know it's
I think people think of the notion of
genius or savant or something and they
think well maybe I can duplicate the
same without having to take all the
steps yeah in between yeah and and I
think you know we hear these stories of
people just from from you know h.5 yes I
will do something amazing and maybe it
is inside of us but it needs a little
coaching or yeah I think screenwriting
though is a bit of a Croft so you don't
actually hear of savant screenwriters
like I've never heard of a five-year-old
writing in great script or even those
17-year old running a great script
sometimes you can get you know the woman
who wrote you know I forget she was
quite a blow because she was relatively
young when she wrote that but we don't
know the back I don't really know
actually what happened there I know some
of the story but it we just it because
it's a craft it it's like like pottery
or something you know you you don't just
if you're a genius Potter you still have
to practice to get the pot to be correct
and I really believe with screenwriting
it is a bit of a craft and so we don't
get these savants we just don't we don't
get the great seventeen year old going
attach the best screen running water not
yet although it might change because the
youngsters not as an axis they have to
filmmaking ability is very exciting and
amazing I mean they've got thing phones
you know stuff on the apps they can just
make music videos just like that so
maybe it'll change maybe in the future
the ability to make what's in your head
won't have this craft in between step
and maybe you will have youngsters
making the best films ever you know we'd
be nice
what's the best screenwriting book
you've read I don't have to remember
what the school you might have to look
it up oh and I'm terrible with names so
there is this there's two actually so my
first thought when you said what's the
best writing book I've ever read was
Chris Vogler's book that was my first
thought because that was the first book
I've read on screen writing it was given
to me and I was like oh wow it's you
know was really interesting and idea of
archetypes and writing to you know the
mythic stories inside us was really
interesting and I think it's seminal so
you know kind of have to read it and
then my second thought was I kind of
like save the cat popped up there in a
way but it was also like it's a
structure thing and I am suspicious of
structure and screenwriting even though
we need structure overly structured
stories for me where the beats of the
story taught the characters motivations
and the characters themselves can result
sometimes in stories that just sit a
little bit uncomfortable with me and I'm
very predictable and you know we just
watched him and we're not as moved by
them as when you're trying to do
something and maybe a little bit
different so I didn't go for that one
then my mind went to actually my mom
read another book called David may a
heresy and common sense for actors was
kind of interesting look David memory
has got a very interesting take on
writing very different to anyone else
so anything the David memo writes on
writing is very interesting and then the
one that just kind of sticks with me is
Alexander Mackendrick on filmmaking
which is a as far as I understand he is
a professor who taught at UCLA for a
while and he was quite a character quite
interesting he wrote this book it's got
two direct two seconds one on directing
and one on writing and in the section on
writing he's just got a really honest
way of writing about the writing process
and he's got some really great quotes
there you know like I can t remember but
like there are three kinds of student
from long to long and very much to be
long you know these are like he's got a
bit of a sense of humor in what he's
writing about sorry like that yeah so
that one that section on writing was was
quite seminal in a way for me even
though I can tell you exactly the sort
of hints and tips that he used it was
just he kind of
you kind of was talking about the art of
writing in a way that wasn't too
prescriptive and I really like that yeah
so that was really I can recommend that
at what point did a teaching opportunity
open up for you when I studied my
masters in screenwriting in the UK I had
to decide that I'm gonna stay in the UK
I'll come back to South Africa
and I decided to come back to South
Africa because there were more
opportunities the UK film industry is
very regulated in a way you have to
almost do Prentis positions to work your
way up the ladder and I came back to
South Africa and as soon as I came back
to South Africa my sort of mentor at the
University there
a woman called Lesley Marx she said
don't you want to come talk to our
students about screenwriting almost
immediately so I just come back and my
I'll never forget my first sort of
teaching opportunity around
screenwriting was to a class of yes
second or third year English students
who also interested in writing and
screenwriting and then I gave a talk on
what I knew about screenwriting at that
time which was hardly anything also
nervous and to write on the whiteboard
now I kind of had this thing about
there's not a step ladder to success in
screenwriting this you know you have to
kind of make it up as you go along in
terms you have to hustle do a lot of
hustling and that was the first time and
then from then on I just guest the
lecture went down really well and so
they started employing me part-time to
teach and then maybe she had turned into
full-time and I've been teaching I've
basically been teaching for the last 20
years very soon that was 2000 so it's
like 19 years I mean teaching and that's
been on and off at various institutions
and sometimes full-time and it's been a
long career so it's interesting my mom
is a teacher and my dad was he worked in
a photography store and was very
interesting filmmaking and used to bring
film cameras home in the early days and
he bought video cameras home and so I
think I'm the combination of the two the
filmmaker and the teacher so I don't
know it's just I love teaching I love
inspiring people to tell the stories
that they really want to tell that's my
my true passion so yeah that's what I
first started teaching of ever since
I've always been doing it yeah so when
you first were asked to teach this class
it didn't feel like
deer-in-the-headlight oh it did Oh
so scared and interestingly enough a
speaking to one of my fellow authors
recently who said when they teach they
still feel nervous and I think it's
quite a good thing I still feel a little
nervous I mean I gave a talk recently
and it was it turned out being much
bigger than I thought of it was like a
studio space and I had a little
microphone thing in there like loads of
people and I was like okay and I was a
little bit nervous but I know when I
talk about what I'm really passionate
about it just flows which is great so
the nerves subside but I think being
slightly nervous because nervousness
sort of fear and excitement are very
similar and there's a saying about fear
is just excitement without the breath if
you breathe through it and you can
access your excitement and then you can
get excited about things but there's
definitely a fear about I think it's
good for a teacher to be a little bit
nervous before they go onstage or before
they go on you know in front of the
class because I think if you bored about
what you're doing and you're like oh
I'll do the same thing again I know it
works it just doesn't have an edge to it
I think there needs to be a little bit
of deer-in-the-headlights slightly when
you start losing that I think maybe your
passion is gone I don't know you know
that is a great point because I've had
different people come at me before an
interview because I let them know that I
am nervous yeah and one of whom was an
a-list actor who asked me why are you
nervous I said because this matters to
me and he was like oh wow and another
person who was a journalist and said you
shouldn't be nervous you should do this
all the time is it and I said I am well
you were nervous before this interview I
was like fantastic because I care yeah
because you care is it you know it's
important to you so yeah I think it's
it's good to be but a little bit of
nerves and before you go in any public
forum it's good I think that's part of
the Western culture though is to kind of
be like oh I got this yeah I'm good and
I think that's false yeah and I think
that's something that there's a lot of
falsity in in in our lives you know
often we we have to pretend to be people
we're not and you know there's that
impostor syndrome that pops up and then
you like am I really this person am I
really good enough am I really a writer
and
you know am i a creative person and
these questions are not really supposed
to be spoken about but people are
speaking about their more and more which
i think is really healing for society I
hope so so yeah
how his teaching made you a better
writer mean conscious of what I'm doing
that is that has been really interesting
because before I was a teacher and I'd
learned some of the writing techniques
and I was doing writing when I had to
express that to a student or a learner
or something and I had to say so this is
what I do or this is how it's done
suddenly I had to consciously stop and
think about wait a minute what do I do
how do I do this thing that I do and
that has made me really conscious sort
of a conscious writer and that process
has been led me to some really
interesting places which I do talk about
in the book but it's also just generally
being more conscious about what I'm
doing on all levels because when you
have to express that to a student yeah
you have to kind of think through what
you're doing and that's been really
great and I think it's also sometimes I
get people giving guest lectures and
they're they're really great writers but
they can't explain what they're doing
they just go I just do it often I also
when I've run film schools and now that
I have taught in film schools and I
especially cinematographers you know
they don't really know what they're
doing that just they just do it they're
geniuses at it but you get a good
cinematographer to come around in
cinematography class they don't know we
just push this button here you do this
thing it's it's it's difficult for some
people to translate what they do into
easily understandable bits of knowledge
you can pass on to students so that was
for me where I learned about myself
because I had to express what I'm doing
that was yeah that was really good so I
think that's made me a better writer in
that I am more conscious of what I'm
doing when I'm doing it especially
around to ilog writing which was
difficult for me in the beginning being
more conscious about writing dialogue
being conscious about writing subtext
you say these things to your students
enough eventually you start doing it
yourself
however there's a flip side to this
which is that a lot of people and I've
spoken to some really famous script
gurus who wanna write and are terrified
because now you're the Guru and you have
to write so there's another flip side to
this which is I've got this story that's
been pecking at my feet wanting to be
told and I have to write this now and
I've written this book
done really well and now it's like okay
I'll write a script now and there's a
bit of nerves around that because you
like from the position of the other you
know the person who should know how to
do it now you've got to do it it's
interesting it's a lot of pressure
can you do it Donald trum bow can you
like right under another name or
something because then you would feel
maybe in some sense less pressure
because people will be just judging it
based on the work not on well wait but
he also wrote this book yes teacher
I think there's a Styles moving around I
think there's a the now that my books
written my name is you know you known as
the guy wrote this book set opens doors
as well so you can so you kind of have
to write that cuz that's the name that
opens the doors and I'm actually fine
with it I'll get over myself and I'll
I'll write it when you talk about
conscious being conscious of things um
it has me thinking about the power of
intention yes how does that also factor
into writing interesting I believe
intention is very important when
rewriting and okay I'm a bit
conservative in some ways I'm not at all
conservative but only way that I'm
conservative is and maybe it's not
conservative is that I do believe that
the messages we put out there as
filmmakers affect the world I only know
this because when I was younger and I
watched the screen I remember
consciously watching the screen thinking
okay if that's allowed on the screen
that's allowed in life like I remember
feeling this thing of like those people
in order to do what they do on the
screen or in order for that stuff to be
they must have passed some sort of a
process or and now it's now it's allowed
and now that's the way we should be or
that's the way we should behave or that
kind of behaviour okay so I do believe
that as as phone creators and I know
this is sort of contentious issue in
some ways some people like just put
anything up on the screen I'm like I
think we need to be careful of what will
we want to create but I'm the kind of
person who doesn't litter because he
wants to create a better world so they
find only litter with the stories that
I'm creating either so I want to have an
intention and my intention with my book
is to inspire people to tell stories
that matter to make the
all the better place like really that is
what I would love to do and when I say
make the world a better place I mean
more equal more just fruitful more
considerate less harm less fighting this
war all those kind of things and I think
that the stories we put out there do
matter and so therefore the
intentionality behind what we write and
why we write is important for the world
in general and so I think we have to be
careful what we create in a way and we
have to also be careful art affects us
so why do I want to write do you wanna
write for acclaim do oh no right because
I want to impress my father you know
they these questions about and I'm gonna
be a happy person even if I get an
Academy Award and I you know do really
well am I gonna be a happy person so
that intentionality both in what I'm
creating and why I'm creating it I think
is really important to kind of make the
world a better place in some way so I
think it's you know it's vitally
important so part of the intentionality
and the importance I think of of having
an intention when you're writing comes
from a lesson that I learned early on in
my career where I wanted to write above
all offset all I wanted to do was write
I wanted to you know be paid to write
and to make a movie and so I wrote a
slasher slasher horror film because I
knew that it was cheap to make I knew
that it would get funding and it was the
kind of thing that I you know that one
could make I don't watch national horror
movies myself but I thought okay this
will be fun and I wrote a story about a
whole lot of students on their way to a
rave in the desert sort of like like the
burden Burning Man and they take a wrong
turn and they get lost and they get
slowly but surely hacked to death by an
apartheid experiment gone wrong and he's
too genetically modified dogs and it was
a kind of a slasher horror thing and it
was pretty dark and it was like I went
to places that were quite gruesome and
it did get some funding it got funding
from one of our national funders a
production company was interested in
doing it they
raising funds I was talking to
eventually some people in LA who were
mad they were crazy they were like can
you rub the wings off the plane and I'm
like no you can't do of the wings of the
plane he's not that kind of a monster
anyway but it was it was my intention
was to make a foam at any costs and I
remember when you're doing some location
scouting for the phone we went to this
farm beautiful farm in the desert and
there were these trees in the distance
and there were beautiful trees and I
said oh that looks just like what the
landing script could be for the plan
could you take the trees down and the
farmer was like sure I'll take the trees
not no problem you just wanted the job I
wanted us to shoot in his land and then
so I was gonna go and destroy trees in
nature which is not really what I am
about make a movie that scared people
made them not want to go out into nature
because the story was basically about
these kids going off to explore and God
the world and their story but truly get
killed by this you know horrible monster
so that for me the effect would have
been that people would have been scared
to leave their homes you know they were
just that fear that horror movies can
sometimes you know would have been even
more and then the message behind the
film would have been like don't cut into
nature because people will kill you and
also I'll destroy some trees in reality
on the way for making this film but I
still wanted me I didn't even at that
point I didn't have that real
realization but the story ran into some
difficulties - production company split
up the other production company wanted
to keep the foam I think and eventually
I used to dread getting emails about
this and it turn into a nightmare one of
those absolute night where I was just
like huh and then I realized do you
really want to make this film Matthew
can you imagine that we're gonna direct
it can you imagine sitting there in the
scene with this girl with like wrapped
up in the razor wire and you saying like
more blood we need more blood like it's
not I'm not that person I'm really not
that person so what I learned from that
was that my intention was to make a film
at any cost and become a film director
at any cost and actually if that had
happened I'm not sure I would have been
in a very happy place or would have
created a message that
improve the world in any way necessarily
it might have I might have done the
exact opposite of what I started out
trying to do so that's why
intentionality is really important to me
and I think it's important as a writer
to think further along the line at what
effect will this have on me and the
world when I'm writing it however you
also can't censor yourself so that's
definitely to come out we came up I just
worked in the formal school for two
years I think was very angry at students
and so therefore I wrote the slasher
harmony where students get hacked to
death so maybe that helped me very
beautifully in some ways so yeah you got
to I don't want to like say limit
yourself I just want to say check your
intentions sure it was there part of it
to where you wanted to write to the
market yes definitely
oh yeah absolutely no for sure I wanted
to write to the market and what I found
really interesting is in my original
intention in writing the slasher movie I
my original intention was I'm gonna
write a movie where the main character I
was trying to find out what is the main
character's strength that makes him kill
the monster I wanted it to be empathy I
wanted the main character to empathize
with the monster in such a way that he
could actually understand where the
month two was coming from and somehow
solve the problem of this story
however the genre itself does not allow
that to happen I realized that the hero
in a slasher horror movie cannot
empathize with the months they just it
just didn't work in the end and the
structure itself of a slasher horror
movie was well the hero has to kill the
monster that's just you know at some
point he has to physically overcome the
monster with violence which is the way
that a lot of you know stories work and
so I found that my original intention of
actually pushing empathy as a character
trait didn't work at all was there a
period in your life where you really
wanted to understand story so you even
more so you hunkered down and devoured
everything from watching films
screenplays yeah I have a funny story
about that I think in a way is that I
when I was really young I read the trial
by Kafka and I think I was too young for
it I was I think it was I don't know at
15 or something I get I remember it
really left an impression on me because
there's all these dreamlike images
but I didn't understand it and I think
that evoked in me this need to
understand story because I was just like
I don't understand what's going on in
the story
it's freaky I like it but I know what it
is and I think that kind of solving the
puzzle of Kafka's of the trial led me on
this journey of writing and and
understanding writing I think for sure
yeah and that was yeah that was seminal
what does it mean to tap into a well
when it comes to story
so yeah in this in my book the three
worlds of screenwriting I use the
metaphor of a well because for me wells
are you know I mean the desert they
needed obviously to kind of provide life
blood of you know of water and of plant
but like what it is survive you can't
really survive in a desert without them
and I don't think we can survive without
stories and so for me tapping into it
well is taking that metaphor and
expanding it a bit and and digging into
either other movies you've seen or your
imagination or your memory and literally
drawing up water which are stories to
kind of feed the tribe and I was just
like the idea of a well because wells
are mysterious you know they go down
into some sort of a ground water and the
groundwater seeps everywhere and
connects everything else so I think that
there's something like the collective
unconsciousness that young talks about
is in a well you know you kind of you
never know what you're gonna find down
there it's going to be surprising to you
hopefully but it can also be really rich
and life-giving so for me that's what I
mean by tapping into a well I think I
got the idea from overhearing a composed
to talk about how when he composed music
sort of classical composer that
sometimes it felt like he was just
tapping into an underground river and
the music was this river just flying and
he could tap into it he could just
listen to the music and for me if a
story comes do you like that that's and
that's amazing so so yeah it's it's a
Tareq but it for me it talks about the
creative process in a way that's really
real for me yeah I like that you think a
lot of writers are tapping into this
they could it could be well or even air
up above you think that's something that
when they get into like this right
mindset and they're in their favorite
writing environment definitely
it's beautiful when it happens it's
sometimes difficult to get there and the
point of my book is to help people get
there but often we can feel stuck and
we're not in that space or flow flow is
also like this flow reminds me of like a
river where a well can draw from in a
way yeah it can be really difficult to
get to that space but when you're in
that space as a writer you kind of
recognize it I think when the characters
start almost behaving and talking by
themselves and it's like this weird
world that you've imagined but it's
alive then we're then we're in the floor
of writing and that for me does feel a
bit like drawing from a well so I think
that's yeah that flow the underground
river that we sort of tap into it can
also be a lightning bolt from above
there's been many you know angels
inspiring us the muses inspiring us I
mean a lot of stories as to where ideas
come from but I think you know it when
you feel it when you're writing it's
great and it's like and well for me time
stops things slowed down I don't eat I
don't worry about anything I just write
when you read about some people who've
written famous works or famous songs
they they don't know where it comes from
it just the song comes the story comes
that's that's an amazing space if you
can get there it's interesting that you
say that some days it's very difficult
to get there because even with runners
or even people who walk there is sort of
like a walkers higher runner's high but
Sunday's it doesn't happen it's just
either you're off or the world is off
like some tragic stories out there and
you can feel it around you and it's just
like I can't get to that place today
interesting can you not get to that
place even if you're writing for 20 for
a while does it do vanish you just come
what is it sometimes never come on the
whole run for me sometimes it just
doesn't consummate I don't know and and
I don't know if it's just it's more me
or it's the environment or its to like
you know if it's more traffic yeah let's
say you're trying to and so you're
stopping and starting and you can't
really around that that's interesting
because I think from a writer's point of
view sometimes you can write and the
whole sessions frustrating and you lack
I didn't get to that place I'm a failure
this is terrible
but you just have to go again and that's
that can be very difficult I think like
really really difficult yeah and you
just push through
and just get out of vomit draft as a
quality environment draft just you know
just you vomit it out and even if it's
terrible
somewhere along the line once you've
done that and you go and rewrite you you
may hit that space again but it can be
very limiting for people I think it can
be frustrating writing can be
frustrating even as you know surprising
jargon can be frustrating him I've just
started surfing which has never really
been for us it can be frustrating but
it's always clerical when I leave the
water but it can be very frustrating but
it really what it's just because you're
waiting for a wave and then doesn't come
when you're not catching it at the right
time no more like if the conditions are
terrible in the waves everywhere and
they hitting you and it's like crazy and
it's chaos and you just like and you
can't catch the wave sometime and you
bail bail bail and back the wave just
goes past Union like I've literally
shouted like I've actually paddled on a
surfboard and I'm paddling and then I I
miss the wave and it turns into pounding
in the way so I think it is what you
bring to it as well I think you know
this is why I mean surfing has taught me
about what I bring to the surf if I'm in
a frustrated mode that it's a way of
releasing it nothing maybe in writing
it's the same you were saying about you
jogging it can just be you maybe what
you bring to the jog before and that's
also why conscious writing in meditation
is kind of important because she kind of
you're aware of that it's not writing
that's the problem it's maybe and it's
not me that's the problem but it's just
everything that I'm bringing to it and
so there's a bit of a freedom in that
yeah do you feel closer to I'll just
call it the source the universe a higher
power or whatever when you're right sure
it's a very interesting question
not always I think I can write and not
be in touch with my higher power or
source and actually be very far from it
but think that I'm doing the kind of
writing that I should be doing and this
is where I think I can get lost so with
the slasher horror story I'm not sure
that was in line with what my higher
power or the source wanted me to write
because my intention was in the wrong
place so for me being in conscious
contact with my higher power is very
difficult daily thing that I have to
keep
and to translate that into writing I
think merely the fact that I'm writing
doesn't mean that I'm in touch with my I
even it might feel creative it might
feel fun but it's not always sometimes I
may be I don't know doing it for the
wrong reasons in a way I don't even
answer the question but sometimes when
I'm right here does feel very like
aligned and everything just kind of
flows and you're in the flow and
everything's perfect
and that does feel a little bit higher
power yeah it does feel a bit like a
divine intervention that kind of thing
you know Zeus lightning bolt from above
you know it can feel you know I need to
do more writing that's what I suppose
it's making me realize because I think
when I am writing in tune with my power
or whatever it's it can be really
powerful yeah I know we've talked about
intention a couple times during our
interview today
what if somebody knows their intention
is not exactly in line with them but
they know where they're going to write
anyway so they were aware yeah I'm
writing this for the market yeah I'm
writing a revenge story whatever it is
and I know that and I'm gonna yeah and
then there it is yeah I mean I think
that's interesting I couldn't be in that
space the revenge stories are so
interesting to me because revenge
stories are like I mean I don't want to
go on a whole tangent but I might know
gonna stop me I won't I bet I'll give
you trouble revenge stories for me or
you know when I was fifteen or sixteen
or you know and I was a long-haired goth
and I was depressed revenge stories but
all I thought of all the time and so I
find revenge stories are almost like
juvenile and they just they just kind of
spurt out and they're very easy to
access so yeah I I think if you want to
write that then I guess it's fine I'm
just not really interested in writing at
myself and I'm not really that
interested in watching it because it's
never it's not gonna teach me anything
new it's gonna teach me what I knew when
I was fifteen you know it's not there's
nothing there's no insight into the
world for necessarily for me in a
revenge story I think however yeah
sometimes you just have to write for the
market if you want to earn money and you
know someone's got it but I think it can
lead you into difficult spaces you know
can lead you to places that are maybe
not the best and but the very nature and
structure of movies actually is you know
an individual overcoming obstacles
fighting things getting what they want
and very often more often than not
especially now in the age of Avengers
and movies killing the bad guy with
brute force and then winning you know
that's the you know the American Way it
really is anyway it's like you know
might makes right I'm stronger than you
and I can shoot guns faster than you I
can punch faster than you know Holly
therefore I'm the goodie and getting out
of that paradigm is a really difficult
thing and I think that that paradigm has
got us into a lot of trouble as a
society but finding stories that have
different solutions to that problem is
exciting for me and that's where the
real cool stuff happens so like even in
Doctor Strange at the end of Doctor
Strange the Avengers movie he negotiates
with the monster he actually says I'm
gonna keep doing this I'm gonna keep
coming back in time and I'm gonna keep
being here unless you leave me alone and
the monster then leaves so I was really
interested in that in that they found a
solution that wasn't normally like in
[Music]
Wonder Woman which was one of them was
lovely but in the end she had to beat
the evil guy by fighting him physically
with power and overpowering him and
therefore she won
where is Doctor Strange had an
interesting twist to that anyway it's a
I find it interesting because we almost
trapped in this structure of movies to
relive the individual overcoming
obstacles because that's what's easy to
watch you know it is nice to watch I
mean I watch they don't give more i
watch all the Avengers movies I like
them but but I find the solutions always
disappointing because they almost always
involve being more violent or stronger
than your opponent and I don't know if
that is gonna lead has led us it may
have led us into global warming into you
know political issues that we have you
know it's quite possible that that kind
of narrative is limiting and I think
that there's more interesting narratives
and those narratives are actually being
explored in television so interesting
the TV series the dirt always have to be
that one you know sort of what 1 or 2
hour long sort of you know 120 minute
structure they do things a little bit
differently
and so you have more complicated
solutions to problems in the TV series
world which is I think maybe also why
people are drawn towards TV now besides
just the impact of Netflix and you know
there's the stories that are being told
there are more neurons more interesting
and the solutions being offered to the
problems posed by the narrative are I
think more interesting in the television
space at the moment and maybe more so to
the art house cinema yes I think so yeah
yeah
Auto cinema has always been a place
where that's being explored in some ways
but I was here you know um I watched I
mean looking to watch some movies while
I'm here because you know I'm in America
I want to watch movies in America
because it's a different experience
watching movies in America is to
watching them abroad because you know
marry and when you're abroad you're
watching it's almost like American
movies are foreign films which is
bizarre because I grew up with the
television American television as much
as you guys did here and I've watched
lots more but they still foreign in a
way but you hear you're like okay these
are people here it will speak this
accent and they're all here and this is
the world that I presenting so it's
interesting watching American movies in
America there's probably something to
that but I couldn't really find anything
to watch at the cinema I was it was a
bit sad I was like AMC diner I loved it
as I said before what can i watch and
then there were a few you know feel good
alternative smaller stories but they
were the feel good alternative smaller
stories that I've seen hundred times and
I'm like I'm not really interested in
that anymore so yeah it was difficult to
find something I'd rather watch TV maybe
they should have AMC donnas and they
show TV series okay well I'm there's
some great hard art house cinema in LA
it's it's excellent and and the stories
do feel to me more satisfying and
they're not the the endings of course is
not it's not always a neat packaged
ending and I think that's the beauty of
them so anyway yeah I've said it many
times so you talk about the three wells
in your book how does someone know which
well they should tap into for their
story so it's a good question I can very
quickly share quickly explain the three
wells so you can see what they are and
it's a very simple concept it's and it's
linked to meditation would be spoken
about before is when I slow down the
moment of creativity so if I'm writing
and there's that flashing cursor and I'm
seeing that flashing cursor in front of
me you know were you writing on your
document and I can draw from three
distinct sources within myself in that
moment of creation
the first is are the movies that I've
seen or anything about read books that
I've read any media that I've consumed
that is not that I haven't created I
call that the external source as well
then the other one I can tap into is the
imagination well which feels like a
lightning bolt from above it's just
imagination I just make it up feels like
I've made it up feels like it's come out
of nowhere and that's the imagination
well and then the third well is the
memory well which is my own deep
memories that I can tap into but it's
difficult to go there sometimes but
they're mine they're like my lived
experiences all my senses were alive
when I experienced whatever it was that
I've experienced and so those are the
three different wells and when we write
we just automatically tap into whichever
one when we're writing it depends on who
we are depends on what we're writing so
if I say to you now very quickly I was
just trying to do this experiment and
imagine a scene set in
a symmetry or graveyard and you have to
imagine some images that come to your
mind
chances are the first thing that you
imagine or from external sources well
green grasses headstones priest standing
with a little Bible it's raining maybe
it's raining maybe they've got umbrellas
do all the stuff that is in the external
source when we write we often write
that's the first thing we write it's
very easy to access and very good if
you're writing to a deadline to write to
the external source as well the
imagination while is a bit more tricky
if I say imagine a the scene said in the
graveyard that you've never seen before
it becomes a bit of a oh wait a minute
okay or something happens there that
you'd never imagined before then it
becomes more difficult but sometimes you
can have an idea it's like ha and then
you write pillar and your imagination
just kind of flies or if I say imagine a
cemetery that you've been to that you've
experienced or something that you've
seen in the cemetery and then you have
to kind of slow your life down it's more
difficult to access that but then you
can sometimes draw from that and you'll
find really interesting stuff there so
when we're writing unconsciously when I
write unconsciously I'm very often
tapping into the external source as well
I'm writing movies that have existed
before and maybe imagining stuff up but
I'm not putting any bit of me in it
because it's difficult to do that for me
some people by the way just not right
from the memory while immediately and
they just stack their own you write
stories that then that they've
experienced and then they still
sometimes they write stories that are so
much in their memory wall that they're
boring and they need to start tapping
into the external source as well and
write you know draw from some other
movies draw a structure from other
movies or scenes or something and
imagine a bit more to make your story
but more so it doesn't a there's no real
clear distinction as to which well you
should tap into when you write it
depends what you're writing it depends
what stage you are at writing it I have
a personal preference for the memory
well because I believe that's where a
lot of authenticity and resonance comes
in and I think even if you're writing a
slasher horror movie and you've drawn
mostly from so that horror movie I wrote
was basically
The Hills Have Eyes which was a old
movie they redid it recently was that
mixed with dope some personal
experiences that I've had but if you're
adding a special movie you may not have
to grow from your memory wall that much
but maybe if you've written something
and you're really written it and you
want to pump it up a bit go to each
scene and even think of the location and
then draw from your own memory and say
wait I haven't been in a location like
that or similar to that and what was my
experience there what stayed with me in
my memory and you put that into your
scene it can be something small like the
sound of cicadas or something just put
it in your scene suddenly in fact it's
alive because you remember that from
your actual lived experience and then
suddenly you can make a scene that is a
bland scene really really resonant so
yeah that's where so it depends on which
well you want to tap into at which time
depending what you're writing I know
that when my publisher first asked me to
harness it if I'm writing can you not
have a graph that says I keep you
writing a slasher horror movies gotta be
eighty percent external source as well
ten percent imagination and in ten
percent memory I'm like well not really
I'd love to be able to say that but
that's not really the way it works the
creative process is a lot more organic
so much so that when you write and you
might not be consciously aware of what
while you're tapping into and then only
when you rewrite you might say wait a
minute
I've just copied all the other movies ya
can't put something else in oh this is
just my story no one's gonna relate to
it how can I find other stories and put
maybe me inspired by the structure or
characters from other stories and put
them into my story so yeah it's a it's a
difficult question to answer because
there's not just one well that you have
to tap into at a time with all three
happening at once and you can pump your
story up by suddenly being more
imaginative
you know you've said your senior but
wait you imagine maybe it's somewhere
else play be like a child you know just
play and imagine but get my scene is set
in the living room it could it be set in
a I don't know like a roller coaster
ride maybe and then tribe doesn't work
oh wouldn't work but at least you were
using your imagination for a while some
living rooms are like rollercoaster
rides what's going on
let's suppose someone's tapping into the
memory well the memory well is very
traumatic
is that a signifier that that's where
they should be writing then so the you
know I'm not a qualified therapist but
the person in me my gut answer is yes
definitely but there's a caveat on that
which is that the memory wall can have
some traumatic stuff in it and if you're
not in a safe space and you're writing
from it and you're writing something
that's traumatic it could open wounds so
I think you need to be supported if
you're gonna be writing from that you
need to feel supported you have
therapists you have family members you
have a friend you need to have a husband
or a support structure you need support
structures in case I think if you're
gonna write from that space because it
can result in people accessing stuff
that's really traumatic for them but I
do believe that that's way that you
healing happens for you as a writer
which is really important and then maybe
the healing can happen for the world if
you can express that space that you've
been to in a way that others can watch
it and go yes I've also been hurt I have
the same wounds as you they're just
different that can really heal the world
but it's a it is a so yeah that's why my
answer is as you can see I'm excited I'm
like yes we must write the stuff that
hurts us but it can be difficult in my
kevie a is especially going to be using
this in an educational environment
you've got to be careful about the safe
space that you create ironically people
are very eager to share that if you give
them an opportunity a safe space they're
actually very eager to go there but it
can result you've got to be careful with
what you're doing but yeah I would say
that's the stuff it resonates with you
it's scary for you it's challenging to
write I have something I want to write
my next story and it's like I am so
scared of writing this thing but I feel
like I'm gonna do it because it's it's a
story that hasn't really been told and
it's it's but that that hesitation that
I have I think is a good thing I want to
push through that and and get it to it
it's really interesting you talk about
that safe space with I remember being in
a class that was not a writing class but
but he shared something that was just
devastating and I felt that the teacher
didn't protect this person and allowed
the other students to just throw advice
on what they needed and I I saw the
change in the person and I wanted to say
something to them I couldn't because I
felt like it wasn't my place but it
wasn't it wasn't a safe space and so I
think that that is an interesting
engaging yep if I tell this story how
are people going to react because not
everybody's gonna be like wow that's
great that you would share that yeah
some people absolutely it's so difficult
I yeah it's I mean I've been doing this
kind of work so the book came out of
somehow feeling that people needed to
tap into their memories and share what
they have experienced in screenwriting
mode because a lot of the stories that
my students were writing will
half-remembered stories from other
movies they'd seen or weird imagine
stuff ways to do with pregnancy or
prostitution or something I don't know
why the students are always interested
in that kind of drugs or gangs something
like not to do with their life
and they were always right past issues
of stuff and we're not got them to write
something from their life like the day
it all changed some really powerful just
a three scenar thing well you know it
was amazingly powerful but I found that
I had to create a really safe space to
do that and so I often have the class
sit in the circle I even sometimes make
household hands and like pass a little
pulse around the hands you know you can
only really share with us your turn and
I've had tears people cry people laugh
it's a very amazing space and you know
that one or two students share where
I've said look you know you should go
and speak to someone professionally do
you have anyone in your life you can
speak to and then I will pass them on to
a counsel if that's needed but it it is
very important to create that safe space
and how do you say in my book like this
is powerful stuff if you're going to
teach from it create a safe space and
again and I've actually had some
feedback from people who've said like
I've done some of your exercises but I
had to kind of turn them down a bit like
the one was write your saddest memory
she's changed it to write your saddest
memory for the month
you know something sad that happened to
you this month so you can you can adjust
it but yeah you can imagine
if you're writing that it can be really
really moving and powerful ya have to
have a safe space
storey sloth to story sleuth what is
that you've seen bits of my book yes
stories lot to story sleuth is about so
one of the ways we access the memory
well is through senses and being aware
of the world when you're in it and very
often I find for myself I my thing that
has been taught me through the world is
to disconnect from the world lie on the
couch watch TV read a book even reading
a book is an escape I love it but I must
admit it's an escape because you know
the world is a place where there can be
many things that we feel can injure us
and when we grow up often as a kid you
know things just happen and you're like
oh I need to protect myself I'm gonna
just like very often watch TV screens
which is by the way more and more
happening I went out to dinner the other
day and they were just kids all the kids
had screens the place even had screens
for the kids I was like wow and so we
can numb ourselves and turn into a bit
of a Slough you know even lie on the
couch and just be a sloth so for me a
story sloth is somebody who just sits at
home on the couch and just like numbs
art and then when they're writing
they're writing from a sort of a numbed
out position almost but a story sleuth
is someone who's looking at the world
being open to the world investigating
the world constantly finding stories
every because they are everywhere and to
do that we have to be open to the world
slightly in some ways we have to have
our magnifying glass and look at the
world and be open to it and allow senses
to operate and be present this is again
it links up to meditation but being
present in the moment of the world and
folding around us in order to be open to
those stories that are out there
it can be traumatized for me it can be
I'm like I mean I'll see somebody
walking across the road carrying a like
a flip file and they're going somewhere
and then hurry they dress smartly in lap
oh that guy's going to a job interview
he looks so traumatized know if he gets
his job interview like you know I can
relate so much to the world it can
sometimes be a bit overwhelming but I do
think that that further is a
riot is is to be a story student to
Gotha and find the stories because they
are everywhere I mean they they can be
overwhelming as to how many stories they
are actually so if you have a stuck and
often my book you know this the byline
has never be stuck again because it's
about breaking through writer's block
breaking through that that limit that we
can feel if we walk around their stories
lose they are just stories everywhere
and I mean it can maybe that can be
overwhelming but also you could just
write the story of the guy going to his
job interview and that'll open up
something so yeah for me this the the
movement from stories fluff to stories
smooth is moving from the couch into the
world and there's a great quote which is
something like how vain it is to sit
down and write when you haven't stood up
to live and I like that wow we need to
stand up to live we sit down to write on
it right you know so that's the story
story sleuth going out there looking for
stories and living in the world and
being present and being open you know
not too much because I can also drive
you insane
but yeah yeah have you experienced
writer's block yes I think I have
experienced writer's block probably
quite a lot I have a trick that I do a
few tricks that I do to avoid writer's
block but one name is if I'm writing
something I and I know that there's a
really exciting scene that I'm gonna
write them like heading up to that scene
then I'll just start writing the scene
and I'll stop I wouldn't finish writing
it so that the next day when I have to
sit down to write I'm very excited about
finishing that scene when I experience
writer's block I almost feel like I've
written everything out that I've got in
me already in that one session of
running and then I might put and then
the next morning I wake up and I'm like
oh oh wait T now so the excitement of
writing helps it helps me to stop
writing a scene in the middle of the
scene that I really want to write and
then keep that excitement for the next
day but that means already that I mean a
writing space where I'm writing every
day but to get into the place where
you're writing every day can be even
more difficult I think and that's where
the blocks that's a bigger block I think
when people talk about writer's block
I think they often talking about sitting
in front of the computer stuck for me
it's real writer's block is I'm not even
sitting in front
you know I'm not even near a computer
I'm like I'm somewhere else I'm like I
don't know on the couch or I'm not even
you know I'm eating breakfast or I'm not
even at the computer yet that's where
the real blocks happened because I'm not
feeling that I have enough to say once
I'm sitting at the computer then another
kind of a block can happen but that's
easily overcome by just writing anything
professional writers do that you know
they just write every day they just
force themselves through the writing and
even before they writing they know it's
terrible
it's fine I'll come back and I'll fix it
later in the edits and then that's a
that's maybe a different kind of
writer's block but yeah I've experienced
both kinds the sort of not even be able
to sit in front of the computer writer's
block and then sitting in front of the
computer feeling feeling blocked it's a
it's a strange space but for me it does
help to be able to tap into these wells
like a carry away what's my memory on
this okay do you have an interesting
memory around this huh and then writing
it oh okay wait a minute let me just be
imaginative let me just be playful
let me just imagine something totally
random it's probably terrible but I'm
gonna write it anyway or one of the
movies of our scene ah there was a scene
I was cool I can write that so for me
tapping into the worlds breaks through
the writer's block very very easily and
very effectively yeah
and there aren't there many schools of
thought on on writer's block even
somewhere there you say there is no such
thing as writer's block yeah I think
this is why when you ask me have I ever
experience writer's block I'm like mmm
define writer's I don't really know when
people talk about writer's block and I
don't mention it in my book I just say
never be stuck again and I talk about
the whales and how they can help us be
creative because I don't really know how
to define writer's block I think there
may be many different kinds like as I'm
talking about it now I'm actually
enhancing here there's different kinds
of writers book these like resistance to
writing in general then there's sitting
in front of the computer and feeling
like what you're writing is terrible and
therefore not being able to write so
maybe that's two different kinds and
then I don't know maybe there's another
car
but yeah I can think of two right now
and a lot of professional writers will
say no there's no such thing as Rhys
book you just sit down and write and
there is there is that you just sit down
and just type the words but what it
feels like is it feels like I'm writing
something that's really terrible and
this feels disgusting but what I've
learned to do is just push through that
and write the disgusting stuff and then
fix it later yeah
how can a writer develop characters
using the three wells of screenwriting
okay that's it's kind of super easy it's
one of the easiest ways to talk about a
chapter in the book on writing
characters from using the three wells
and just to give you an idea if you have
a character and they can be a very minor
character or a major character but I'll
just use a minor character for an
excellent for an example because it can
show you how kind of powerful the wells
can be if for example you've got a
character there's walking into a store
and they have some meeting with the
store clerk do you know as a clerk at
the clerk at the store and they're doing
something and they have some dialogue
between them so this is a minor
character the store clerk is some minor
character who you could just write as
store clerk one but if you want to kind
of use the three wells to maybe pump up
that character but you can look at your
external source as well and make a list
of characters from movies that you like
they could be absolutely random
characters but then they should be in a
way just I like this character I like
this character I like you know the guy
from the shining I like I don't know
it's just anyone I like okay the Michael
Corleone you from The Godfather
being evil the good movies now for some
reason whatever watch recently I like
the Spider Man's best buddy in
spider-man and he's funny and you make a
list of all the movies characters from
other movies you've seen and then you
take your store your store clerk and you
say could he be spider-man's buddy from
that other maybe he could be
spider-man's buddy from the other movie
and suddenly your imagination well he's
kind of lighting up because you're
making a collision of two things and
suddenly you've got this oh wait what
happens if he was spider-man's buddy
from the other man the clock sudden he
has a character's got glasses he's a bit
chubby and he's like really funny and
maybe he's like you know wearing
maybe he's maybe what you buy from him
he says something about linked up to
movies or comic books and now you've got
a character certainly just from from
doing that so that's a it's almost like
a like a Rolodex you flipping through
all these characters that exist before
I'm putting them in kind of minor parts
of your movie you can do it with a major
character but then you need to take
elements from different characters and
put them together and so you take you
know the sort of I don't know the anger
of one character mixed with the daddy
issues with another character mixed with
something from and then you can create
sort of composite characters using other
movies it can be really fun and can be
really effective and can spark of your
imagination well this is how you do it
you you kind of collide ideas together
and in that collision of store clerk and
spider-man's buddy your imagination is
just suddenly gone off and he's suddenly
a much clearer character by the way when
you write that into your script when you
read the script the character leaps off
the page because suddenly your minor
characters have become really really
interesting the other really fun thing
is to go into your memory wall and go
mmm
clerks without experience yeah that
could be one thing you could do or you
could say by the way this is what it
looks like tapping into the memory what
always takes a bit longer because you
have to kind of look into your own life
and it's like slows down a bit and
you're like okay so there's this guy
Kevin yeah he's a buddy of mine he's got
his hair shaved on the side it's got
tattoos all over him and he's kind of
like quite a fun guy is a bit strange
got interesting way of talking what if
he was the clerk oh yeah that could work
well maybe it won't work at all maybe
some of the characters but what you can
access in your memory well it's
absolutely unique characters that no
one's seen before and then suddenly
they're the store clerk and then
suddenly or you're stalk leaps off the
page I actually had this experience in a
story that I wrote I think I talked
about it in the book where I had a
manager in a music store so one of my
characters had a shoot made her own
songs and she was trying to get her
songs on she she would put them onto a
DVD disc like a CD and try and sell it
to the store but the store clerk the
idea was that she's not gonna get that
salt because the store clerks just like
it's against company company policy and
the store clerk I just chose theirs
ran for my life totally tattooed
everywhere piercings everywhere long
hair slightly effeminate I think he
might go buy another gender at the
moment it's I'm not sure but he or she
is the store clerk now in the in the
movie and suddenly the character was
really alive and he was interesting and
my character was trying to sell her
songs had a baby and she was holding the
baby and at some point she passes it to
the store clerk man is holding his
babies like it's against company policy
and it's like is it does he mean holding
the baby or does he mean the CD and
suddenly there was like a whole into
action so drawing from the memory well a
new minor characters can really pump it
up but also I think in the major
characters so when you creating
character is is a real art form actually
and and you know people spend a lot of
time you trying to watch your backstory
of your character what's the history of
a character and there's there's some
something about being able to empathize
with your character sometimes you have
to draw from your own experiences around
something similar to what that
characters gone through and then
suddenly it becomes really real for you
and then suddenly starts resonating for
you and that character matters to you
and then you write from that position so
that's a summary of how you can beef up
characters using the three wells yeah
there's a whole chapter on it so you'd
have to to get into it might take a
while but yeah those those little
samples I mean I promise you you just go
through your script take all your minor
characters use the externals of all your
memory well and your script will
suddenly have a lot more life and when
people read it they'll go ah wow that
character leaps off the page what's he
done different well not much she's just
attached something to them so they yeah
so they real I guess it's about trying
to create something that is a real space
for the reader I like that I like that
clerk analogy because you can think to
ones in movies but then you can also
think to ones let you experience that
you first maybe didn't think about or
ones that really stood out whether they
were really nice or thank you one time I
had someone accused me of stealing
something and he accused me right at the
register why and I said oh you didn't
see the receipt for the thing in the bag
from the other store that I went to and
then it was like this awkward even
talking about awkward moment
love me that story yeah and it was great
because then I can't had to keep seeing
him but I knew in the back of my mind
and he knew and I didn't say anything I
wasn't gonna call him out or yeah it's
amazing
but I that was such a vivid memories are
interacting with a clerk and they've
been great times when look around
they're they're fun and but but that's
true it seems like such a minor thing
but if you look and then if you look at
back what you've told me now
is the scene that's got subtext amazing
subjects like going back to the store
when you know and he knows and ready
there's great subtext there and that's
the stuff that really works and movies
you know so actually a movie that
haven't seen is the farewell which is I
was just going to go see that okay yeah
well that's one movie that I think is
gonna be really interesting in that I
heard the podcast that is based on
because this American laughter the
podcast of the fair basically the
farewell was the podcast many years ago
and she and when I wrote the movie and
now directed it that movie I think is
gonna have many moments of subtext
absolute complex subjects because of the
structure of the movie but also because
it's based on a memory well it's all
from a memory well and so that kind of
everyone's trying to teach how to write
subtext it's very difficult you almost
have to either the characters must be so
alive or you have to draw from life and
then you get that immediately you talk
about story and subtext it's in your one
memory that popped up in your when I
mentioned Clerk you were like yes I've
got that Iranian everybody's got that
and yours is unique if you wrote that
scene it would be a unique story sure
that's so funny that you note on the
farewell mmm great excellent
we may have already covered this but
I'll say it anyway because you never
know about leads okay did you like yeah
realistic dialogue using the three wells
yeah so there is again a chapter in the
book on round dialogue and and using the
three wells of writing dialogue I find
for me writing dialogue was really
difficult in the beginning some people
can just write dialogue oh by the way I
was gonna call my book
you can't teach screenwriting because I
wonder sometimes if you can teach
screenwriting and dialogue writing in
particular is something that some people
come to my classes they just write
pretty entire like I'm like how did you
do this what do you do but people are
open to the world again it's about being
open to the world and listening to the
way people speak and also understanding
that if you set a scene in your movie
it's gotta be as realistic as your own
life so in your memories if you're
writing a divorce see where say a scene
where someone breaks up with someone
often what I find people right on the
nose dialogue so they like I am breaking
up with you now and I'm like when I
broke up with people did I ever say
those words I don't think I ever used
the other words I have broken up with
some people unfortunately and if you go
into your own memory while you look at
how how did that happen with me is there
anything I can draw from this well it
wasn't a moment was it just like silence
it's not working anymore what isn't
working I don't know this whole thing
it's just and you look at the scene
maybe you parked your car and seafront
and you're like yeah to be many years
but I think it's definitely time and we
just you know and then okay you know so
you don't actually say in life very
often we don't say like these pretty
clear moments however the difference
between live dialogue and screen
dialogue is that we do have to clearly
communicate to the audience that they're
breaking out so you know this kind of is
where you go your external source as
well and say well how did they do it in
that movie and do I need to actually say
at some point I do have to say we are
broken up officially so the audience
understands that they've broken out and
this is the difficulty between what I
call street dialogue and screen dialogue
and well stage dialogue is also typical
stage dialogue it's all about the word
you know often not all stage plays but
often stage plays is about language it's
about you know the uses of language and
street dialogue it's totally different
that screen dialogue as a writer you
writing because you have to communicate
some information to an audience through
your characters and that's the delicate
balance is using your memory well to
write realistic sounding dialogue but
then also using the external source as
well and knowing that it's it's got a
serve a purpose it's got to move the
story forward so sometimes it has to be
slightly on-the-nose but it shouldn't be
too on the nose obviously so yeah that's
how you would do it but I find some of
the difficulty I had with first-time
writers is trying to communicate to them
that what you're writing must be as real
as life you know it's got to be even if
it's said in space you know like an
event just keeps coming up like I'm and
leaving that message for paper pots when
he's floating up in space it's got to be
real you're in space but it's got to be
real so he can't say the things he wants
to say and then he'll eventually say
them because you want the characters to
care about him but it'll take him a
while and that's why that seem kind of
works really well because it's it feels
real and and often when when first-time
writers write they don't write like that
and so how to teach that I don't know
how you teach that but you got a drawer
from your life you got to draw from your
life experiences you need to be you need
to be empathetic with your characters
I'm teaching that as difficult so that's
where the three wells came from as well
is that I found when people started
drawing from their lives they were like
oh it's really easy that's how people
speak I'm like yeah and they should
speak like that in your movie as well
maybe yeah so yeah and sorry the other
thing is the symbolism sleuth is if
you're going out there and you're
listening to what people sound like when
they speak castles are very important
especially if you've got regionally
specific accents and you ought to write
that then you gotta go listen you know
to listen to the way people speak that's
very true yes because I have especially
here in LA you'll hear people from all
over it's amazing and the different
things that they'll say and the
terminology yes I remember one lady I'm
not sure where she was from but she was
like they're gonna call the law on him
these are coming and I was oh yeah
that's right okay and I didn't know it
Wow yeah I like that cold pool you know
and then you'll hear other people that
you know just just different
terminologies
for somebody said we would call
something else you'd asked about
principal vs. headmaster yeah there's so
many MLA particularly I just noticing
all these different accents every week
it's overwhelming I'm like even though
the waitress who served us last night I
was wrong I can't place her at all
anyway but it's interesting she has such
a unique way of speaking it was just
like it sounded like she was a I don't
she had a high-pitched voice but it was
also like he was a sportscaster or
something but she was also maybe Spanish
like background I don't know it was
difficult for me to figure out what she
was saying West the time but it's a be
losing a favor what I'm saying what's
the time as well that's really funny
anyway speaking of dialogue this is a
total aside but it's just a funny thing
that happens to a South African in LA
it's really funny is this so I was
surfing and this guy was surfing his
board he fell off his board in his board
was I think he's brought up and I gave
it to him I was on the shore and I said
something like oh I see your board has
got space for two fins which is anyway
which is a strange sentence you wouldn't
normally say but I could see his face
and his face was like this human being
is talking to me I think he's talking to
me in English
it's definitely English and he's
confident in English but it's not
American and then I said it again and
then he was like okay he is speaking
English he is very confident I needed
like adjust my brain to understand what
he's saying and then I spoke it again
and then he was like Amy understood me
but it's really funny to see that happen
you know it's just it's fertile aside
but it's in terms of dialogue you know
like the miscommunication that can
happen with dialogue is really funny and
then the subtleties the subtext it's
mean it's just I find it really funny
because like English is my own language
this is the way I ask people and I speak
it here every time I see this look on
people's face it's classic it's the like
this man is not from America and he's
talking to me I've never spoken to a
South African before I don't know what
this space is is really a great look
anyway I'm sure Trevor Noah understands
lucky for Trevor Noah
thank goodness for Trevor now he's
opened up the door to South African
accent see right and the musk family -
exactly and the my family good for you
young are you anti plot against plot in
the middle so I'm deaf you know against
plot I wrote sitcom for 25 years is all
about plot Edward breaks happen at
certain times you need to have certain
things happen in certain places to
motivate the advert breaks
interestingly enough now though with
television not having so many advert
brakes you know with Netflix where you
its on-demand and so you don't have your
advert breaks I think I do think plots
changing slightly the three-act
structure and the terminology around the
3x structure that's developed over the
years it's really useful after you've
written something I find and I I just
can't get this out of my head but for me
it feels like human beings have been
telling stories for thousands of years
before we've been analyzing them so like
we talked Tory's naturally around the
campfires you know we told stories about
the hunt 'mad way to find the animals
there was some sort of structure in that
in a way yes there was a main character
trying to find an animal and there was
following throughs and so there was some
sort of a structure already to that
which is maybe a universal myth I'm not
sure but we've in time stories for a
long time longer than we've been
analyzing stories so for me plot and the
analysis of plot can be a real source of
people getting stuck in their writing
because they feel that they need to have
a plot that works before they right now
if you just write without a plot you can
also end up down a dark hole of loose
ends that you know leave nowhere and
just right for the rest of your life
without having a structure but I find
plot and the analysis of plot a good
place to be once you've written
something but for me plot arises out of
characters in a space doing something
and that creates the plot the characters
themselves are almost it's like this
whole separation of character and plot
is is not actually real when you're
either creating it or watching it
character the plot are intrinsically
linked we separate them in order to
analyze and maybe in the rewrite write
our stories better but I do find that so
if you just focus on plot and drop the
characters it can result in stories that
are feel a bit empty and it can result
in stories that everyone's written
before what I find really funny about
these books on plot and some really good
books are written on plot and I point to
them in my book I don't talk about plot
at all in my book what I find really
funny about books on plot is they'll say
these seven beats need to be in a story
they don't have to be there in that
order they don't all have to be there
and I'm like what do you mean they don't
have to be there metal and they don't
have to be there this is kind of it's
like a weird and if you read closely
they've all got this disclaimer of like
you know they don't have to be in that
order and they don't have to necessary
all be then I'm like well what are you
really trying to say so I'm slightly
suspicious of generating your idea
writing from plot first I think it can
be really useful in the rewrite it's
definitely really useful in the story
edit I use it all the time when I'm
trying to help writers strengthen the
strengthen their stories but actually
the best villain plot that I've ever
heard the best quote on plot and it's
not even about plot it's from that book
on filmmaking that I mentioned earlier
by Alexandre Mackendrick he says
something like the only thing you need
to know what's happening now in your
story should not be as exciting or
interesting as what may or may not
happen later it's reasonable what is
happening now shouldn't be as
interesting or exciting as what may or
may not happen later so something's
happening later and it's drawing the
story forward and it's that thing that's
happening later that you need to put in
your plot somewhere so we need to know
that something's going to happen in the
you know you need to set it up so that
something's gonna pay off and that'll
drive the story forward and they'll keep
people watching oh I like that because
it's kind of an escapist you know it's
not really part plot but it's kind of
linked to structure in some way so yeah
I I'm not anti plot but as a matter of
fact I'm Pro plot when it comes to
analysis of the story and trying to make
it stronger because I do believe you
have to take a sledgehammer to your
story once you've written it and hit it
and either breaks something's wrong with
the structure and so you need to like
make it work but I sometimes find that a
lot of the even when people use plot to
analyze movies they try and identify
like the inciting incident and they do
it in the same movie the engine to buy
different places and I'm like what is
this it's not an exact science I think
writing isn't an exact science and
people who claim that it's an exact
science are actually lying in my
experience of writing is it's not an
exact science
it's it's a bit
to that and so yeah so I I kind of worry
about the usefulness of extremely plot
driven writing books they can be useful
for some people in some places and I
wrote from that for a lot of my life
what is taking a sledgehammer to your
story though like how do you
metaphorically do that so yeah I always
think of it like this when I when you
write from a character-driven sort of
perspective or from a maybe a more
organic perspective you tentatively
connect scenes together to form a sort
of like a structure and it can be a very
fragile crystalline structure it might
not be very strong and taking a staged
hammer to it means asking yourself those
really hard questions that structure
sort of asked you to ask in a way is
like what is your character want now and
have you told us it early enough you
know and you hit it in fact if it
survives it survives or when is the
transition into the new world or winners
are transitioning to the second act is
that stronger is it clear enough that's
another so these are the kind of taking
a sledgehammer to your story and if it
falls apart then it's probably not
strong enough but if it's really
crystalline strong enough structure that
holds then maybe your story is good
enough that's kind of what I mean by
taking a stage Hammett's all those
difficult questions that story execs
will ask you or you know people who read
lots of books will ask you and and and I
think I think we we do have to do that
we can't be Precious about our stories
either even though they these for me
they can be really beautiful creations
that come out of a case of good
intention at some point they're gonna
that you know your audience is gonna hit
sledgehammers at it and does it hold
does it not hold you know you have to
you have to put it through the wringer a
bit that's when you're bringing Rob from
the key they do that with screenwriting
videos to trust you know they do
I know it's hilarious I wonder sometimes
how useful they are they may be useful I
[Music]
definitely came from that position in
the beginning when I was when I first
taught definitely I was all like you
know why are you doing this
just like this sort of but there's an
anger around that sometimes and I wonder
about that I actually do question where
that's coming from where is this sort of
anger towards story so I was coming from
a place of insecurity because I was I
didn't really you know had written much
I was like you know and I was like - oh
my god these students what am I gonna do
I'll be strict because you're I'm strict
and now listen to me I have changed now
I'm gonna look more soft and I'm a lot
more nurturing in the way that I help
people burn their stories into the world
as opposed to you know try and kill them
as they arrive so yeah yeah I suppose I
am actually suspect of a way that the
intention is coming from in the in the
shotty story people that can shot at
people you know the drill master story
guy I'm like yeah
I don't know it seems to be coming from
in this late place I just think seen it
for I guess my first interview in Ali
and I'm gonna get kicked out of the
tongue no no no like the scene in
Forrest Gump Gump you know one needs to
like right in his face and what do you
story yes
resonance that's your first job yeah hmm
what tell us what that's about
so resonance for me is I have a quote in
that chapter my books got quotes in
every chapter I'll have a lot of quotes
in this interview but I have a quote in
that chapter that begins with which is
this it is it's a complicated quote and
it might not be easily - I'm just to
understand just saying it but it's a
quote from Gustave Flaubert Madame
Bovary and the quote is something like
language is a cracked kettle on which we
beat our Tunes for bears to dance to
while all the while we long to move the
Stars to pity
so it means language is we want to move
the Stars to pity with our language we
want a language to be this beautiful
thing that expresses everything we
feeling and expresses our emotions but
actually language is a cracked kettle on
which we beating our Tunes for bears to
dance to then why be as a dancer but
it's that good language fails us when it
comes to certain things I really believe
I think
things like religion and faith language
fails us and logic fails us at that
point and I also believe that with
creation when we create things language
fails us to really explain what's going
on at the core of creativity and that
moment of creativity which is kind of
what my books about so my little KVA is
always with the word resonance the word
resonance came out of an inability to
explain what happens to me when I'm
watching a movie and I moved or when I'm
looking at a painting and I'm moved
or when I'm listening to a piece of
music and I moved I use the word
resonance there because for me it feels
like something in the painting is
vibrating and it vibrates something in
me and I resonate with it and that's
what I mean by resonance is I look at a
painting like for example yeah I look at
a painting for example in the van Gogh
Museum in Amsterdam there's this one
particular painting that I saw
we'd filled with crows which is a
beautiful painting and it's just really
moved when I was in the museum looking
at this painting it really moved me and
resonated with me in a really deep way I
hope it wasn't because I was in
Amsterdam and things can move you there
which shouldn't but I'm sure it wasn't
that but other things moving you know
paintings and moments and movies move me
particularly music will move me
characters behaving in a certain way
will move me and that movement and that
resonance is what I'm trying to create
in the scripts of my writers or my
writing is how do we take that resonance
how do we make our audience in reading a
script never mind watching it but how do
you make that in them resonate with
what's on the page that for me is the
real trick of writing and I do believe
between we do that by doing what
Hemingway says we do which is it's very
easy you just saw the typewriter and
bleed you know we take our memory while
we put it on the stage we put our pint
of blood on the stage and that's what
the way we create resonance cuz if it
moved us in our memories if it stayed in
our memories for some way so for some
reason it might have had a resonance it
might have this charge that we then put
on the page and then people reading and
resonate with it so that's kind of what
I mean by resonance of course it can get
really complicated because you do need
structure sometimes to get to that point
where people are moved you know you need
it have certain things in place so that
you know you we care about the character
so that when they do something we moved
by it but I still believe that they're
certain
sort of events in our lives even objects
and senses and sounds and touches and
tastes which we free take from our
memory where they have they carry this
weight of resonance you put them on the
page and there it is and it's a it's a
it's a difficult thing to to do
consciously but you can and it's also
difficult to kind of talk about because
it's so abstract but you recognize it
immediately when you see it I mean I
know you know what I'm talking about but
it's difficult to kind of do it except
by accessing your memories and being
very vulnerable it's also about being
vulnerable I think and putting yourself
out there you some of some of your
vulnerability and then people will
resonate with it I think because if it's
too much of just your own vulnerability
it becomes a manifesto without that
structure exactly this is where you know
what I always say is like I don't want
this book I don't want to hear about
your life your boring life because I
actually don't I want to hear about
something else maybe you know I don't
want to just read about your life I want
to read about I want aspects of your
life to be present in the storytelling
and that's different the storytelling is
a story it's you have structure it
should have you know and but but you put
your memories in the aspects of it and
then it really starts to come alive and
just to kind of go back to the story
structure thing maybe and back to that
van Gogh painting cuz I love that van
Gogh painting it was using an example
because I know I don't know what van
Gogh was doing when he painted but I
know that he didn't have a test audience
and he didn't read a book on
screenwriting theory and you didn't put
his painting up and say to everyone
right guys look at this painting are
there enough crows in this painting we
filled with crows or the other do you
want more yellow and then hand out
flying forms and then the audience all
filled it in and then like handed it
back to him and he changed it so that
didn't happen so he was doing something
else which i think is easy was
resonating and he was just moving with
emotion you put that on the canvas now
of course he didn't have to pay millions
of dollars for that canvas which is why
you need maybe audience test subjects to
give you you know see if your movies
working or not but if you write from a
position of okay I've got a please an
audience I'm gonna make money out of
this and let me read a book on structure
I don't know if you hit the resonance
not always
what makes a great story I love the way
you ask these questions they're just
like he has this question I've prepared
earlier that is gonna get to the heart
of all issues they're all the questions
I have okay for me a great story I
almost want to break this question into
two okay The Escapist great story as in
Star Wars Star Trek James Bond spectacle
movies you know born the Bourne movies
which I love all these things there's a
roller coaster ride escapist stories
jaws and one of these things is that was
not so much maybe because jaws actually
has some interesting stuff in it going
on but the other movies all that but but
you can have these escapist movies and
if those are great stories they can be
graceful is very enjoyable they're you
know the entertaining spider-man far
from home I watched it in the cinema
surround-sound it was fine it was
escapist it wasn't a great story but you
know it was fun
and what should it was cool I don't know
just those stories they can be great
stories but for me a great story is when
you have when I when I leave the cinema
and I have been granted a new way of
looking at the world and I leave the
cinema and I'm like I've got some
insight into how to behave in the world
in a different way that I had when I
walked in which could be an insight into
a character characters behavior they're
behaving in a way that is interesting
complex a con can't understand what
they're doing but I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave the world leave the cinema in a
way that shows me different way of being
in the world that for me is a really
great story it's like we learned from
stories I think you know we learn how to
behave in the world in stories so if the
story is teaching me something new about
the world and my place in it fantastic
and you don't have to do that by
preaching so the Godfather is clearly a
great story Michael Corleone's
motivations are really complex and so
complex that we question our own
motivations like his motivation he'll
claim his family
the most important thing to him but at
the end of the three three movies his
wife's left him his she's had an
abortion he's killed his brother and his
daughters died in front of him
so he's no family this is a great scene
in the second one I think ways so here
at the table he's insisting as I mean
everyone leave until he's alone at the
table there is no family around anymore
so we're learning something about our
own desires my own drives now and you
know and we look at that when we go like
hmm okay he clearly wanted this but he
got this in my own life what do I want
am I getting that you know so this
movies that question our own
complexities as human beings those from
your great stories and they're few and
far between but you know I don't know
why I'm I seem to be in the 70s but that
often is where I am when you talk about
great stories but I think although under
Raging Bull whether that was 70s but you
know Raging Bull is another one of these
stories where you just like it they
complex characters and and they're
flawed and they're interesting and we
leave there going like that was perfect
like don't change I've seen but you you
looked into this character's life and
now you've given me something in my own
life and I've I've resonated in some way
is the resonance word again with the
character on the screen because it's a
kind of a real portrayal of the person
struggling with life without clear
answers and then we leave going and then
we may our dealings with other people
might be affected by that because we
don't know what this person has been
going through you know so it's like yeah
so I don't know if that answers the
question about it's a great story
because I'm not telling you it needs to
have three act structure and you said
this and listen this but it needs when I
leave the cinema I want to leave the
cinema a changed person in some way I
mean that's my goal ideally yeah and
going back to the clerk analogy I
actually had another positive experience
where the clerk said oh yeah hey how's
your day going and I said oh great sorry
I I spaced that I'm still thinking about
the movie I just saw so that right there
tells you is it that it's affecting you
20 minutes later exactly and sometimes
those stories cinema has that ability
you need going into darkened space for
like an hour or two it has all the
chances in the world to affect your life
and you can just also just put someone
in the world and you leave that cinema
going
I love that space it's my favorite space
you know where you leave and you carry
the movie with you it's great right and
again we can also see there was a movie
I saw where I felt so bad for this woman
I mean she was really crying during I
mean I'm just really breaking down and I
think it affected her after the film and
you know I just let her be and I'm not
trying to like stare at her make her
feel bad but I felt how affected she was
about this one scene and it was probably
because something similar just happened
something and I was like wow that's
amazing
that's a meet you know it's okay it's a
powerful medium and I think we again we
have to be well we have to be careful
because like okay I'm gonna go yeah
because you can cut this up but
sometimes my students have all people
that write they know that I've been
working with it they'll write a scene
often of domestic abuse because it's an
issue that's you know people are you
know we don't talk about it enough
because it happens at the silence around
it is a problem but it happens and some
of the people write it in the movie but
they'll write it in such a way and then
maybe the movie gets made and and it
gets portrayed in such a way I always
say to them what about the abuser in the
cinema and the abused woman in the
cinema how they gonna feel about this
and then even the worst for me is rape
scenes you know because a lot of them in
movies enough how is the rapist gonna
feel in this cinema or a woman who's
been raped because we I think we have to
think about these questions because I
think if we want to reach the person
whose life we want to either support or
change so I'm talking about the rapist
in the room or the victim of abuse we
have to speak to those people and we
have to be sensitive what we're doing
and if you're having an obscene where
the guys taking a woman's head and
smashing it into a wall Tarantino what
are you saying with that
what are you community what's the person
sitting there feeling what they feel
what emotions are they feeling at that
moment are they feeling like yeah it's a
scary thought but I do believe we carry
that much power so I don't know where
that came from but it came from your the
woman was affected by the scene in the
movie that you were talking about we
yeah this is what we're dealing with
actually we're dealing with a very
powerful medium that
affect people and so we have to ask
ourselves that put out again paralyzing
ourselves almost ask yourself that
question go deep it okay this is what's
gonna happen in the scene and this is
what I'm gonna show and this is the
these are the images that I'm gonna put
on the back of people's retinas and in
their brains for the rest of their lives
and whether you like it or not you got
that afraid from me I don't know I find
it a there's a responsibility there with
great power comes great responsibility
anyway maybe yeah I was just thinking of
some quote and I don't know who said it
but artists are the most dangerous means
they have the power to yeah with this is
acting Plato as the Republic the artists
of the first ones that he kicks up
because he's like no I got a country in
you know you wants to control the
society create the perfect Society
artists painters out get out banished we
see it everywhere any authoritative
regime will crack down on the artists
and the journalists how does the writer
know the beginning of their story so the
beginning is a very difficult time as
June the movie begins which David Lynch
maybe he hates movie but it's a great
quote in the beginning I think she says
Oh nourishes the beginning is a very
delicate time so the beginning of a
story is the most important part I think
the first 15 minutes like any issues you
have in your story it's all going to
eventually work back to the first 15 10
minutes of your story it really is a
difficult time I think it's when you
first write your story
chances are you gonna rewrite the
beginning so because you're gonna get
into some sort of a structural mess at
some point you have to rearrange things
and adjust it and come back to the
beginning and normally the beginning is
later than you think so you know you may
think your story begins here and you
start writing it and then you're like oh
it actually my story begins much later
than that that's often the case in first
time first drafts you know you write
your first draft and it's like you think
your story begins way back in Arkansas
but actually begins when they arrived in
New York you know you don't need the
whole Arkansas stuff you need the guy
arriving in New York so stories I think
the beginning so if that's what you mean
by how does writing at the beginning of
their story
you may think your beginning is there
but it might not be by the time you get
to the rewrite and you'll probably
rewrite your beginning more than
anything else unfortunately people
actually arrived in beginning more exact
way they start when they open the
document it's like at the beginning
which is a problem you should actually
rewrite your middle and end as much as
you rewrite your beginning but your
beginning will change as you write
because that's when you're setting up
everything that's what you're setting up
like you know that's for me it's like if
your story is an arrow flying through
the sky this is the pullback on the bow
you know and it's as far as you pull
back and it's where you aim and then by
the time you get into your second act or
even off it three or four that you let
go so that's a very important moment the
beginning and how does it write a know
where the beginning is that you probably
don't until you've getting into the
rewriting process and then you change
where you begin almost more than more
often they're not when you rewrite are
you rewriting from the very beginning or
are you going back to where you sort of
like how are you breaking up the
rewriting so I probably do go back to
the beginning a lot but I try not to it
just seems to be the way things happen
so your first 15 pages are fantastic and
then the rest you kind of tend to forget
about the beginning and the end are the
most important so for me the biggest
question someone can ask themselves is
what do I want the audience to feel when
they leave the cinema the moment they
leave this in I mean in that last frame
when the last frame comes up and it
finishes what I want the audience to
feel at that point and in the rewrite
process I go back and look at everything
and say does that serve that feeling
that emotion at the end if not I need to
change something it might be in the
beginning of my from the middle it might
be at the end where you have to change
that that thing so yeah I don't have
that answer the question but that
question is that's questions in my mind
all the time what I want the audience to
feel when they leave the cinema and does
the scene serve that if not do I need it
can I change it can I toss it so then
yeah I guess when I rewrite I rewrite
from all over the place but the
beginning is so vital that you will not
be writing that a lot
yeah do you feel like people really
neglect rewriting the middle yeah and so
a lot of problems happen because your
that definitely interests I think look
you know the middle of the second act
problems is like it's a cliche I think
that that is a that's a result of just
structure and just that it's it's it's
like a tentpole
you know because you've got your
beginning awesome you know you know it's
gonna end fine middle and lots of shirts
so it is it's a nature of the feature
film beast if you're talking about
feature films that the middle is going
to be difficult and but I do think
people end up not writing that just
because from the simplest reasons you
open up your document and it's gonna
open up on the first page and you're
gonna rewrite and then I find like even
the craftmas of so if the structure
doesn't change much the dialogue doesn't
even with the craft of the script itself
in terms of the words used and the spot
the sparsity sparsity of the words used
and the precision of the words used is
often better in the beginning and then
she can halfway and it just becomes
messy so yeah I would actually encourage
people to not do what I do but to start
when you do your rewrite try and
discipline yourself to I am only
rewriting from scene 12 today and then
I'm only running from scene 26 because
you know to make sure that you pay as
much attention to that as you can but
yeah it's a standard error I guess I've
seen it a lot when someone presents you
with their scripts and they say I need
you to help me make it better what are
you looking for what what are the main
things they're gonna stand out to you
first usually very often when I we're
not when I'm in that position with
someone who's giving me a script and
says you know do I want it you know what
can I do to make it better my question
is why do you want to tell the story and
very often when I do that I am tap on to
unplug and tap whatever a-hole well of
stuff that's not in the script like very
often people will say I want to tell the
story because of this doesn't happen to
me and I was younger right
and there's the story there's some stuff
let's put that in the script so very
often I think
the first step for me is always always
always why do you want to tell the story
and if they say well to make money and
to you know be the next superhero movie
then I'll say cool okay let's look at
structure and it's fix it with the
structure and then characters and stuff
as long as I know why you want to tell
the story but then if I dig it a little
bit deeper there might be something else
okay well so it's the reason you want to
tell the story because you feel a little
bit insecure and actually need a claim
and money to survive in the world okay
what happens if your villain has got
that same problem in your superhero
movie
ooh now suddenly it's alive you know and
then so so you can unpack a lot just by
asking someone why they want to tell the
story and then you try and apply that to
the script and then make it a bit better
so that's the first thing I'd say and
then I'm looking for resonance when I'm
reading the script I'm looking for you
know is this fresh is this original is
this authentic to your to the story
you're trying to tell and can you make
it more authentic by drawing from your
memory well or from other and you know
any other sources to make it stronger
and then you know you ask all the normal
questions like who's your main carry -
what does he want why do I care about
him you know all those kind of regular
screenwriting questions which anyone can
ask but for me what's more interesting
is why do you want to tell the story and
it's funny that people will write a
whole feature film through without
knowing that I also don't know I mean I
wrote my coming out of Suburbia script
and only when I did a rewrite with
another writer that had come up like Oh
jeepers my main characters fear is that
he doesn't want to leave suburbia
because he's scared of the world out
there because I'm scared of the world
I'm scared of success and you know all
of these things and that's my characters
problem and I was like ah and then
suddenly everything changed so it's a
bit of getting involved in yourself that
can get really strong then suddenly the
story becomes very clear and you know
that's what it is
that's what it's about so yeah I would
say that's my first and then like you
know is the formatting correct that's
another story you know basic formatting
errors in scripts is like it yeah that
can be a problem from people you haven't
read enough scripts in I understand you
know they even they're using final draft
but then I understand even if you're
using file rough doesn't mean your
formatting is necessary correct you can
still you know you can override certain
things so yeah so yeah from the sublime
to
you know why do you want to tell the
story to the most mundane which is is it
formatted correctly these are the errors
often in first-time scripts present
anything that stayed with you from your
time in the UK something a professor
said to you yes that's you apply oh
there's two there's two statements so
two things that I learned in in when I
was in the UK the one thing in studying
the one was drama is conflict and I
remember they told me that and at the
time I was really against conflict and
I'm still against conflict in terms of
physical you know fighting for some you
know for something because you weren't
something and somebody else wants
something and you fight about
or you know that kind of conflict and I
remember like underlining it angrily in
there I scratched it out angrily then I
realized after it's okay they kinda
write it is about conflict like
everything there needs to be something
so for example you know if the story is
about you and I and then this glass of
water and we both want the water we have
a story you know as an actor you can do
that you can act it you can perform it
you can find strategies around how to
get the water and that's your strategy
that's my structure you put them against
each other so I think there is conflict
but it might not be physical actual
fighting conflict there can be
strategies that you can apply and and so
I think that drama is conflict I've come
around to the to believe that so that
was the one thing that just kind of
stuck with me because my first reaction
to it as the student was like now it's
not and then I was like okay okay
ya know what's the conflict in the scene
I need to know what why am i watching
this and there needs to be something it
can be very simple it can be that
someone's got a piece of I don't know
sticky paper on his face and you can't
get rid of it and that there's a
conflict between him and the sticky
paper but you know there's conflict and
I'm gonna watch until the conflict is
resolved and that's what I what is
interesting and human beings tend to run
towards gunfire and away from tears and
what that is about us but we want
conflict we seem to want it so yeah and
then the other thing that stayed with me
was use the white of the page
somebody said that use the white of the
page and what they meant was I didn't
know it took me a long time to figure
this out but it was that the layout of
your script and how you use your action
particularly your action you know so if
you write you instead of just writing a
block of action you break it up into
sections so that the script looks
beautiful it looks like a script but it
also reads like the movie so in other
words you use your enter button as like
a like a cut almost you use long
descriptive passages if it's a long
lingering shot in your mind you short
sharp sentences if it's short sharp
sentences if it's a you know kind of an
action scene you can have like
explosions of dialogue here off of
action here and there so use the white
of the page is great because it starts
to talk about the craft of screenwriting
and talks about the voice of the writer
so the more scripts you read the more I
start to see oh this is the voice of the
right and that's about the white of the
page because it's it's basically like a
poem
it's a beautiful it's a visual document
as well it's not just a novel you know
you can't say use the white of a page
for a novel because novels is just
written they just text but if you think
about it with a script it's even where
the dialogue is placed and how much
dialogue there is is it kind of gives
you a feeling it gives you a turn now
turn ality is actually what moviemaking
is all about is you know what is the
tone of this film what is it Reza and
get come back to resonance how do you
create the tone of a movie in a script
well that's by using the white of the
page and by trying to get the voice of
your of your writing and the turn into
the script and that's like high maths
high math you know that's like advanced
advanced screenwriting is if you can
learn to use the white of the page and
you know you're doing something really
well